[Applause]
my kids loved his Aquaman is it cool if
I bring them out and maybe they ask you
a couple questions I do have two and
then you can sit here I'll sit you right
here you good yeah this is so funny
because usually rubies on the bed when
we're watching a nature like Indian he's
like he's like I love all that he's like
you got Aquaman shoes on right now
oh my god he's gonna be quite okay RIT
why don't you take over you have a
question for him yeah okay go ahead
oh you forgot here I'll tell you you
told me in the thing do you know a
little mermaid hey that was her question
in my office and I was like ask him
Ariel yes she's she Ariel's very sweet
she's very nice she's also a redhead so
yeah I'm gonna teach you about redhead
someday they're they're very passionate
very passionate people that is true you
had you had another question in the
office you want me to okay here I love
you okay because they were like this is
the best part they wrote out cards her
and I'm like thank you
[Music]
Aquaman okay to the bathroom that's what
she does in August where does Aquaman go
to the bathroom everywhere do you want
to ask me anything you want to say
anything roomie hey y'all come and you
watch yeah Wow
she's like she said she's the talker and
he's the sensitive boy he's sucking hey
he's chill with Aquaman you chill it all
right
well you guys did awesome good job I
[Applause]
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this